the need to provide a safe convenient
and efficient traveling experience have
given rise to the smart transportation
market it accounts for seventeen point
six percent of the overall smart cities
market segmented by type let's see how
IBM integration capabilities can help
serve transportation customers with new
compelling digital experiences Anna
lives in New York and frequently travels
to meet with clients of her small
business she's just planned a meeting in
California and she tweets about how
excited she is to soak up some sunshine
detecting the tweet the airline sends
her a targeted email offer when Anna
clicks the link she's taken to a
personalized travel tool where she can
quickly enter trip details and
preferences using natural language the
tool asks a few clarifying questions and
puts together a full itinerary booking
the ticket hotel and car reservations
IBM integration capabilities allow Anna
to use her travel tool on the web or on
a mobile app which learns adapt and
helps her at every step of the journey
at the airport Anna checks in for her
flight on the app it recognizes Anna's
location and offers Anna special
promotions based on her previous profile
interactions she accepts and buys a
latte with her airline loyalty points
the more Anna interacts with her travel
tool the more tailored her profile
becomes reflecting her food drink book
and movie preferences
after she boards the plane her app
displays top hiking reviews since anna
has been browsing trails on the web she
instantly books a photography hike for
her day off
upon landing and his mobile app notifies
her husband of her arrival and directs
her to the baggage carousel her reserved
car and her hotel a seamless experience
from start to finish
behind the scenes IBM integration
capabilities has enabled all of these
interactions making Anna and many other
travelers happy customers
[Music]